settlers began arriving here in the
1870s also arriving by horse 150 years
later is Shelby opim a proud member of
high River's Western Heritage I love my
horses yes my auntie was a barrel racer
so I kind of got into it when I was
younger three cream two sweetener and a
honey crer Donut for the horse she takes
Charlie everywhere even for coffee to
make him comfortable in different
environments bomb proof I can scream I
can yell stuff like this shouldn't scare
them so this makes them safe when he
goes to a home nobody's getting hurt and
he's not going to go for me but about 6
months ago Shelby and Charlie began
running into trouble with the law they
have pulled me over six times in the
last like six months the last time was
Tuesday and they told me that I was no
longer allowed to ride in town I
couldn't have horses here I could be
arrested and put in jail Town folk
didn't want any trouble they said my
biggest thing was I had concern for her
with the traffic and knowing horses
horses are just animals and they don't
know what traffic is all the time so
peace officers got legal advice on
barred horses from the town Horse
Feathers said Shelby our bylaw says that
we can our High River page you can
actually go on says horses are a mean of
Transportation the only issue is they
poop Tuesday the mayor felt he had to
step right into the middle of it
sometimes you got to clean up the mess
afterwards so that's what we're doing
turns out Shelby was right mayor
Snodgrass says things got goofy when
peace officers got legal advice without
first going to council we're the town of
High River we a small egg based
Community Shel is more than welcome to
ride or horse in through town you
respect the public you respect the other
drivers you're doing it safely but the
other thing is the drivers in their
vehicles need to be doing the exact same
thing and that was that I will continue
riding in town as long as I'm allowed to
the two settled things the oldfashioned
way with a hand Jake Doug Bas Global
News